BOTH THE GOVERNMENTS OF BRITAIN,
FRANCE, AND THE UNITED STATES.
THEY HAVE SENT THIS TO THE
KREMLIN.
TELLING THEM TO QUIT THESE
ALLEGATIONS ABOUT UKRAINE.
THEY PLANTED A DIRTY BOMB.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE ABOUT IT.
LAST MARCH, RUSSIA ACCUSED
UKRAINE OF PLANTING WEAPONS OF
MASS DESTRUCTION.
THAT NEVER CAME TO ANYTHING.
>> LOOK, WHAT HAS REALLY
HAPPENED IS THAT THE MINISTER
OF DEFENSE HAS MADE TELEPHONE
CALLS.
THIS IS TO THE DEFENSE OF INDIA.
WE HAVE INFORMATION.
THIS IS VERY SERIOUS
INFORMATION.
THEY ARE UNDER PREPARATION.
ON WE HAVE OFFERED OTHER
CONVERSATIONS.
SOME HAVE SAID JUST FROM THE
OUTSIDE THIS IS LYING.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD APPROACH.
>> WE HAVE INTELLIGENCE I.
UKRAINE HAD A HUG THE UN OR.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THESE
ISSUES.
THE CHIEF SAID THIS MONDAY THAT
THE INSPECTOR, ONE OF THESE
LOCATED THAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT A MONTH AGO, THEIR
FINDINGS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THE SICKER DECLARATIONS.
NO UNDECLARED NUCLEAR CABLE
TEASER MATERIALS WERE FOUND
THERE.
>> YES.
THESE TWO LOCATIONS WERE IN
KYIV.
I CHECKING WILL BE THE BEST
OUTCOME OF IT.
>> WILL YOU TAKE THEIR WORD
FORWARD IF THEY CHECK?
>> THEY SAY THAT THIS IS NOT
TRUE.
WILL RUSSIA STOP MAKING THESE
ALLEGATIONS?
>> THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO CHECK.
IT IS GOING TO PROVIDE AN
ANSWER.
>> YOU ARE IRRATIONAL MAN.
WHY WOULD A COUNTRY WANT TO
CREATE A DIRTY BOMB RADIOACTIVE
DISASTER IN THEIR OWN COUNTRY?
WHY WOULD A COUNTRY DO WHAT YOU
ACCUSE THEM OF DOING BACK IN
MARCH.
IT IS A CHEMICAL OR BIOLOGICAL
WEAPON.
WOW TO DO THAT?
>> I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION.
WE HAD A FEELING.
AUTHORITIES IN KYIV NEED TO
ATTRACT ATTENTION.
I THE OFFENSIVE ATTACK ON
FRANCE, THERE IS THE
COUNTERATTACK.
IT HAS STOPPED.
THEY ARE LOSING RESOURCES.
THE FRONT HAS BECOME
STANDARDIZED IN ALL THREE
PLACES.
THAT IS IN KHERSON, IN THE EAST,
AND IN THE OTHER REGION.
THERE IS NO MOVEMENT.
THIS COUNTRY HAS NO MORE
RESOURCES.
I IT IS A DIFFICULT PLACE.
IT COULD BE DAMAGED.
I PERHAPS SOMETHING ELSE.
I IF INTELLIGENCE IS SAYING
THAT SOMETHING IS IN
PREPARATION, THE ISSUE IS TO
VERIFY.
I WE WILL BE HOPING.
>> YOU KNOW THAT THE WEST AND
UKRAINE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
RUSSIAN FALSE FLAG.
THE WEST IS VERY CONCERNED THAT
YOU ARE MAKING THESE
ALLEGATIONS AS A COVER FOR SOME
KIND OF EXPLANATION ON YOUR
SIDE.
YOU SAY THAT THE UKRAINIAN
ABOUT A FIELD IS NOW STABILIZED.
IT IS NOT MOVING.
THE RUSSIANS ALSO FACE A LOT OF
PUSHBACK.
THE WEST SAYS THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY --
IS RUSSIA TRYING TO ESCALATE
THIS WAR?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IN THIS
CONVERSATION, THE MINISTER OF
DEFENSE, HE ISSUED THAT THIS
MINISTER WAS NOT GOING TO USE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THERE WAS NO SINGLE STATEMENT
BY THE PRESIDENT OR
SPOKESPERSON.
I DON'T KNOW.
I THERE ARE TALKS ON THE
TELEVISION.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO USE
NUKES.
THAT IS OUT OF THE QUESTION.
SECONDLY, THIS IS FOR THE
HEALTH.
THE UKRAINE OFFENSIVE HAS
STOPPED.
NOTHING IS HAPPENING.
>> YOU SAID THAT.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO REPEAT
YOURSELF.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT WHAT
YOU HAVE JUST TOLD ME.
RUSSIA WILL NOT USE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
NOT NOW, NOT TOMORROW, NOT IN A
MONTH, NOT IN A YEAR, NO MATTER
WHAT HAPPENS.
>> I CANNOT SAY THE NEXT
GENERATION.
>> YOU ARE SAYING THAT YOUR
COUNTRY HAS PLEDGED NOT TO USE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS >> THIS IS WHAT
I AM SAYING.
THIS IS WHAT HAS BEEN SAID.
MY DEFENSE MINISTER I --
>> YOUR PRESIDENT HAS SAID THAT
TO.
HE NEVER MENTIONED IT ON.
YOUR PRESIDENT HAS RAISED
THREATS.
IT IS WORRIED EVERYBODY.
>> THERE IS SPECULATION,
ALLEGATIONS, AND ISSUES.
THEY ARE TRYING TO --
HE HAS NOT --
>> AS YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT PUTIN
HAS MADE VEILED THREATS.
THE WEST HAS SEEN NO MOVEMENT
YOU --
ARE SAYING IS OFF THE TABLE.
>> THAT IS OKAY.
I WANT TO BE REALLY CLEAR ABOUT
THIS.
IT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT WE NEED TO KNOW THIS
MOMENT.
MANY WORLD LEADERS CALLED IT
ABSOLUTELY IRRESPONSIBLE.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO HEAR WHAT
YOU ARE SAYING.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT DRONES.
WE HAVE SEEN A CONCERTED NEW
RUSSIAN TACTIC.
.
THIS IS A TACTIC USING CRUISE
MISSILES, AIRSTRIKES, AND
KAMIKAZE DRONE STRIKES.
I.
YOU ARE SPECIFICALLY TARGETING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT IS CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT IS ALSO VERY CLEARLY ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> YOUR QUESTION IS MUCH LONGER
THAN MY ANSWER.
>> I NEED TO SET IT UP.
WHY IS RUSSIA DOING THAT?
WHY ATTACKS ITALIAN ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE?
GOOD --
>> DRONES HAVE BEEN USED FOR
MANY AREAS IN THIS AREA.
THIS IS ESSENTIAL FOR OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
--
UKRAINIANS ARE AWARE THAT THEY
SHOULD NOT ATTACK IT.
.
THEY HAVE SEVERELY DAMAGED IT.
IT IS NO SURPRISE THAT THERE IS
A RESPONSE TO THAT.
--
THERE IS THE TARGET.
IT IS CERTAIN INTERRUPTIONS.
THERE IS CERTAIN INTERRUPTIONS
IN THE ENERGY FLOW FROM ONE
REGION TO THE OTHER.
WE CAN STOP THE ARMY.
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO ATTACK
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> ENERGY IS CIVILIAN.
>> ENERGY IS IMPORTANT FOR
EVERYONE.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN THREATS
ABOUT TARGETING THE DAM AS
WELL.
>> YES.
THE ENERGY IS IMPORTANT FOR
EVERYONE.
FOR US, THE IMPORTANCE IS THAT
THE WILL COUNTER INTERVENTION
THAT HAS BEEN STARTED BY
UKRAINE, IT IS NOT A SUCCESS I.
WILL THEY ARE MOVING I.
WE I AM NOT A CIVILIAN.
I AM MILITARY PERSONNEL.
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY ARE GOING
THROUGH.
WE ARE NOT TARGETING THIS.
IT IS IMPORTANT.
WE ARE NOT TARGETING CIVILIAN
POPULATIONS.
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO DAMAGE
CIVILIAN POPULATIONS.
WE STILL BELIEVE THAT THE
POPULATION OF UKRAINE SHOULD,
FIRST OF ALL, WHICH THERE IS
THIS TERRIBLE GOVERNMENT THAT
THEY SHOULD GET RID OF.
SECOND, WE NEED GOOD RELATIONS.
>> YES.
I HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN THERE.
I HAVE SEEN THE CIVILIAN
TARGETS.
I HAVE SEEN THE DAMAGE TO
PEOPLES HOMES AND INDIVIDUALS.
I HAVE SEEN THE MASQUERADES.
YOU CAN SAY THAT.
IT IS NOT IN LINE WITH THE
ACTUAL FACTS.
>> OKAY.
GO TO DONBAS.
YOU WILL SEE THE DAMAGE.
>> WE HAVE.
WE HAVE REPORTERS THERE SINCE
2014.
LET ME MOVE ON TO SOMETHING
ELSE.
I KNOW YOU ARE NOT A MILITARY
OFFICIAL.
WE >> HE SAYS THE AIRBASE AT
WAR EFFORT HAS TO BE RAMPED UP.
THERE IS THE ECONOMIC SIDE OF
IT, THE PRODUCTION SIDE OF IT,
MORE WEAPONS, MORE AMMUNITIONS.
EVEN CLOTHING FOR SOLDIERS.
THAT IS IN THE WINTER.
HOW DO YOU INTERPRET THAT?
I INTERPRETED AS THINGS NOT
GOING VERY WELL.
YOU ARE SENDING HUGE NUMBERS,
PARTICULARLY WITH THESE NEW
RECRUITS.
THAT IS INTO A COUNTRY TO GO TO
WAR.
WITH ALMOST NO TRAINING.
THAT IS WITH VERY LITTLE
EQUIPMENT AND CLOTHING.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT IT IS A
BIG MISTAKE TO THINK THAT THEY
CAN WIN THIS BATTLE.
THERE IS THE POTENTIAL THAT
RUSSIA HAS, THAT UKRAINE HAS.
IT IS NOT COMPARABLE.
AT THE MOMENT, UKRAINE IS A
FAILED STATE.
IT IS LIVING ON THE WESTERN
DONATIONS.
IT IS PROVIDING WESTERN WEAPONS.
THAT IS WHATEVER IT IS.
IT IS PUSHING UKRAINE.
THAT IS NOW HALF.
THAT IS BY THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE,
ALL OF THAT.
IT WILL CONTINUE THIS BATTLE.
WHAT KIND OF STATE WILL IT BE
AFTER THIS WINTER?
THERE IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
IT SHOULD BE FINISHED.
OTHERWISE, IT WILL BE A
CATASTROPHE FOR THE PLACE THAT
IS NOW CALLED UKRAINE.
>> DO YOU SEE RUSSIA WANTED TO
GO THE DIPLOMATIC WAY?
ARE THEY SEEKING SOME WAY OUT
OF THIS?
THEY DID ASK ME ABOUT THE
MOBILIZATION, THE LACK OF
EQUIPMENT.
THERE IS THE CHANGING DYNAMIC
ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, LEGALLY,
HE HAS MADE NEGOTIATIONS
IMPOSSIBLE.
IT IS HIS OWN DECISION.
WE ARE SAYING THAT NEGOTIATIONS
ARE POSSIBLE.
WE WILL BE PREPARED AT ANY TIME
TO FIND THE RIGHT SOLUTION FOR
THE CRISIS.